part d
the pipe can hold 50 cubic feet of water
before overflowing for tea greater than
8 water continues to flow into and out
of the pipe at the given rate until the
pipe begins to overflow
right but do not solve an equation
involving one or more integrals that
gives the time w when the pipe will
begin to overflow
alright so the pipe is going to overflow
so we want to figure out that gives the
time w and the pipe begins to overflow
so the pipe will begin to overflow when
there when it crosses 50 cubic feet of
water or you could say right when it
hits 50 cubic feet of water then it will
begin to overflow so we can figure out
at what time does the pipe have 50 cube
of 50 cubic feet of water in it
and so we could just say well
w of this time so
i used uppercase w as my function for
how much water is in the pipe so capital
w of lowercase w is going to be equal to
50. and so you would just solve for the
w and they said right but do not solve
an equation well just to make this a
little bit clearer if dub
uppercase w of lowercase w is going to
be
plus the integral from 0 to w
and actually now since i've already
since i don't have t as one of my bounds
i could just say r of t minus d minus d
of t dt so let me just do that r of t
minus d
of t
dt
so this is the amount of total water in
the pipe at time w well this is going to
be equal to 50. so we have just written
an equation involving one or more
integrals that gives the time w and the
pipe will begin to overflow so if you
could solve for w that's the time that
the pipe begins to overflow and we are
assuming that it doesn't just right get
to 50 and then somehow come back down
that it'll cross 50 at this time right
over here and you could test that a
little bit more if you want you could
try the slightly larger w or you could
see that the the rate that the the that
you have more flowing in than flowing
out at that time which is so this r of w
is going to be greater than d of w so it
means you're only going to be increasing
so you're going to cross over right at
that time so if you wanted that want the
w though you'd solve this now another
option you could say okay we know w is
going to be greater than eight so you
could say okay how much water do we have
right at time equals eight we figure
that out of the last problem
and so you could say
we
at time equals 8 we have that much
48.544 this is a approximation but it's
pretty close
plus
the amount of water we accumulate
between time 8 and time w of r of t
minus d of t
dt
is equal to 50. either one of these
would get you to the same place the w at
right when do we hit 50 cubic feet of
water and then if you wanted to test it
further you can make sure that your rate
is increasing right at that or or you
have a net positive inflow of water at
that point which tells you that you're
just about to start overflowing